[Music]
how did it feel I mean when you got your
results yeah I think more than anything
it felt kind of like relief fingernails
is about a world pretty similar to ours
other than the fact that there's a new
test that's been invented the device can
tell you how compatible you are with a
partner and so this love Institute is
born I created the program to make the
bond of love stronger we're not here to
try to teach people to fall in love that
would be insane we're here to try to
bring them closer together
love is the most elusive thing we are
all looking for love and find something
real Anna is in 100% tested relationship
with Ryan everything on the surface is
great but there's just a little bit of
Doubt within Anna I think she secretly
comes to work in the Institute because
she wants to try and fight for something
that she feels is lacking within her
relationship hi hi me I'm I'm
Anna Amir is working at the love
Institute to try and understand what
love is since the test has been invented
it's been shown that actually most
people are not in love we've forgotten
what it really is to be focused on your
partner the film is dealing with such
massive themes in a really thoughtful
and specific way do you still have
strong feelings for
[Applause]
them you're not just dealing with these
test results you're dealing with love
and the idea of love we all strive for
100% tested love relationships but the
real ity of it is that it's much messier
than
that